>> HELENA: Hi, I'm Helena and I work on the
Android 2 experience. One of the things I
like best about the phone is what you can
do during a phone call. You can look up one
of your contacts, you can look up something
on Maps, or you can surf the Internet. Okay,
let me show you.
Hi, Emma.
>> EMMA: Helena?
>> HELENA: Hi, are you doing?
>> EMMA: Good. How are you?
>> HELENA: Pretty good. What’s up?
>> EMMA: I'm trying to find Lombard Street
where it gets all curvy, and I’m at Polk
& Lombard. How much farther do I have to go?
>> HELENA: I don’t know for sure, but I
can look it up. Let me check on Maps.
>> EMMA: Okay.
>> HELENA: Hold on for a sec.
Okay, I'm looking it up as we speak.
All right, Emma, you're only two blocks away.
Just keep going east and you’ll get there.